joven y aparentemente moderno
inicialmente vladimir putin le pareció
eeuu su nombre con el que podían hacer
negocios
george bush- lo recibió en su rancho de
texas con halagos hospitalidad y un
viaje de pesca en maine pero la
camaradería desapareció cuando estados
unidos invadió irak y expulsó un aliado
de moscú
saddam hussein después de que la guerra
entre rusia y georgia tensar aún más las
relaciones la administración obama
intentó un reinicio en 2019
erróneamente restablecerse tradujo como
sobrecarga y eso fue lo que le sucedió
al vínculo cuando estalló el conflicto
con ucrania en 2014 al igual que con
irak
rusia percibió que eeuu su persigue una
agenda de cambio de régimen en todo el
mundo
los lazos se deterioraron todavía más
con el kremlin fue acusando de
interferir a favor de donald trump en
las elecciones presidenciales de 2016
algo nuestro objetivo sigue siendo
enviar un mensaje a rusia y a otros no
nos hagan esto porque podemos hacer las
cosas a ustedes because we can de usted
show
en las conmemoraciones del día de las
miradas de obama y putin parecían decir
exactamente eso sabemos lo que estás
haciendo y nosotros también la trama
rusa arrojó una larga sombra sobre la
presidencia de trump él parecía ansioso
por complacer a putin en la cumbre de
helsinki en 2018 pero el mandatario ruso
mantuvo la distancia y arrojo esta
famosa frase como he dicho a quién debes
creerle a quien no debes creerle
no puedes creerle a nadie nunca mujer
las elecciones de 2016 no fueron el
único tema que causó revuelo en marzo
las agencias de inteligencia
estadounidenses afirmaron que rusia
intentó debilitar a joe biden en las
elecciones de 2020 esa acusación podría
no molestar a putin después de todo ha
sobrevivido a cuatro presidentes de eeuu